(hip hop music)
- [Narrator] In Toronto,
there's a basketball fan
like no other.
- [Man] I breathe, drink,
everything about the Raptors basketball.
- [Narrator] He's truly--
- My whole life is around
the Raptors season.
- [Narrator] Deeply.
- [Man] For the last 22 years
I've never missed a game.
- [Narrator] A Raptors superfan.
- My name is Nav Bhatia
and I'm Raptors superfan.
- [Narrator] If you've
watched any Raptors games
in the last decade,
maybe you've noticed the
bearded man sitting courtside.
Well, that's Nav and his
story starts in India
and takes him right here to Canada.
Fleeing violence, Nav left
and settled in Toronto.
He worked hard, opened a very
successful car dealership,
and when the city got
it's own NBA franchise--
- The Raptors arrived and I
bought my first two tickets.
I enjoyed the game.
I was cheering the most
in the whole arena.
- [Narrator] The team embraced him
and being a superfan has it's perks.
- When the legend, Kobe Bryant,
came for his last game to Toronto,
he came to me and said,
"Superfan, I want to thank you.
"What you have done because
you have created a culture
"of bringing everybody together through
"this game of basketball."
- [Narrator] He also gets to
hang with Canadian royalty.
- [Nav] I know Drake pretty well.
- [Narrator] But what's
most important about
Nav's superfandom is that he
represents the changing face
of basketball fans around the world.
- Basketball has changed
my life tremendously.
It has given me an
opportunity to integrate
my community, the south Asians,
into the mainstream.
- [Narrator] Nav may be
the first Raptors superfan
but he wants everyone on board.
- I want to see this game
taken to the next level
where all the communities,
everybody, the Sikhs,
the Hindus, the Muslims,
everybody coming to the game.